Hey, listen, a real quick before we get into this episode with the incredible Will Ferrell head like a moment of your time to set the stage a little bit. Now, Sean and Will and I, we went on a smart list tour last year where we recorded 10 episodes live in front of thousands of our biggest fans. This episode with Will Ferrell was the first of 10 and was recorded live in Washington, D.C. and guess what, right now there are more live episodes from our tour on One Dree Plus that you can listen to. You can listen to these episodes four weeks early and add free on OneDri Plus, after which
you can hear them for free wherever you get your podcast. Find OneDri Plus in the OneDri app or on Apple Podcasts. Are we in the cold open right now? We're in the show's helping right now. Okay, so the cold open is right now. We're about to do our first show. It's our first live show. What should we let people...
Let's pray to the podcast God. Okay, pray to the podcast God. What's bringing in? Is it him or her? It's all of them. So it's a day. It's everything. It's all of them. So it's a day. It's everything. It's everything.
It's everybody. It's a world of all-inclusive. Okay, what's the prayer? And the prayer is... Please Lord Pod. Pod. Pod person. Please shine your happy, funny, light, lovely light on our stupid, stupid idea to go live with this pod.
And welcome to the Smart List. Thank you. Washington DC, thank you for having us. Thank you for having us, this is... Yes. And please, above all things, manage your expectations. Yeah. Because this was really, you know, kind of a half a joke, and then we got an invite, and we said, well, maybe we should. Yeah.
But we want to make sure you guys understand. It's just the three of us talking to a person for an hour. Yeah, that's it. There's no... That's it. So, I hope you enjoyed it. Yeah. I mean, there's not going to be any singing, there's no dancing, there's no... We don't even know how to do it.
We sat down, we were backstage, and we were dicking around. Well, make sure you buy one of these. Yeah. Or four of them. Or four. But we were dicking around, We were doing Sing for Real backstage, and then Jason didn't want to do it, because he claims he can't sing.
I can't sing. I don't even sing a shout. You get to know about Sing for Real that we talked about, right? And you guys, have we talked about? No, I don't think so. So tell him what it is. So Sing for Real is, it started a long time ago,
one of the big enemies of the podcast, Justin Thro, JT from New York. He did this bit where we would sing in the car and then he'd say no, sing for real, which means you can't do it as a bit, you can't like embellish, you can't go to a show me, and you can't like do it like that, you have to do it for real. Like sing the best you possibly can.
And it's so embarrassing. Yeah, it's so embarrassing. So will sing for real. But you sing for real, you've done Broadway. No, I like when Will does it. So, will sing for real. No, I'm saying you know how to sing for real. You're gonna sing for real now?
Yeah, you have to sing for real. Give me a song, any song. What is it? Don't stop believing, don't stop believing. Oh yeah, what are the lyrics? Just don't stop believing. Believe in, hold on to that sweet. By the way, it stops here.
We're not going around. Hold on to that sweet by the way it stops here. We're not going around Hold on to that sweet free feeling. Yeah, okay ready but now but now he can't do a bit I can't do it. I can't do it. I can't it. Yes to really sing it really like he's really looking fucking focusing It's the worst Okay, go. Okay ready three two go. Don't stop, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom He's doing it in bed. Oh, oh! All right. All right, so wait, listen. Have you, now have you ever done any musical theater? No way. No, I'm pretty sure that just costs us about $150,000.
I know. Okay, so wait, now listen, we flew and I've only been to DC once before. I loved it, but I was here very briefly. Sean, why don't you just relax and get casual and cross your legs a little bit? So we, uh, we, uh, we, uh, and so we were at phone out here. What am I going to do? You brought your phone?
I, I, listen, I, I'm a doctor. We were driving in from the airport yesterday, and I said I wanted to know where a specific thing was which was I went a Land or no you were driving along and there's some some park land or whatever and go and Sean Seriously said is that where the grassy noles or was it Not a bit Could not be less smart.
So I really didn't know if I'd... Then you explained it. Were we shocking how little both of you knew about anything? That was a real shock. Yeah. Well, he didn't know. I bet you guys were... This came from the
Washington Monument this was this this this started your claim This whole Simple start giving it to them for sure. Yeah, no There's a great. There's a still because it was it was a statement on stage in DC immediately gives a crowd It's a big it's a bit it was a big FU back to Europe That we made it we did it and look we got a monument now and that's true. I don't know if that's true. It's not I forgot we didn't really close that up at it. I had him kind of going out on the sidewalk,
and then we went on to something else, and he literally just tried to get the real answer just now. By the way, it should be in your defense. This is coming from the guy who all you're faxillately are from Maple. Right, Maple, my 10-year-old daughter spends a lot of time on YouTube because it cuts down on my parenting obligations. She, when you say to an actor,
oh, break a leg. I've always thought it's you wish the person and my apologies to people over here. You, you say break a leg because now only a good thing can happen, right? That was, she says no daddy break a leg means if you break your leg you you get put in a cast and that's what you're trying to do when you audition to get put into a cast and that's where it comes from. No, don't don't. Don't I it's too many faces going no way.
Yeah, here's the going no way. Yeah. Here's, they're all turning to each other. Here's the best part, and then he goes, and then he's, and I said, well, maple, when she get that, and he goes, YouTube. Like, it's if it's like, oh, oh, from the news. I see. Also, also, where all the facts come from. Also, sand is called sand because it's neither sea nor land.
Right? Look, they're all looking at their neighbor. I don't know. Yeah. I don't know. Let's verify it. I think it's real. But here's the other thing that happened today that I've never done.
A day of first was we were walking, Jason wanted to walk. Maybe another extra 25, 30 miles. And all of a sudden, you were here. Jason said, why don't we take one of those birds? And I said Marty Bird. And then he slapped me really hard enough. But I never, and I was like, you guys go, this is too complicated. Like, how do you undo the thing and I got to sign up? And the app, he, Jason did it for me. We rode these birds all around town today. It was the best time I ever had. Yeah.
We took the bird from the Washington Monument to the Capitol, and then here to the arena. Or now I get Marty Bird. You're always flipping the audience off, even in your character name. We're sneaky smart on that show. What? Can we speak to Marty Bird? Yeah. Sure.
Where, let me get, let me get the actor studio. Let me get, let me get Marty Bird here. Let me get, let me get, I'll get my, I'll get my, I'll get my, my dumb concerned face on. Yeah. Yeah. Don't you say that. It looks a lot like my smiling face. Oh no. Jason this morning went where he got sort of,
like, sort of madamee when we were in the hotel room. And then he said, do you know what your face is doing right now? Because they're looking at his face with this and he goes, am I smiling? No, you're doing the opposite of smiling. We have covered this on the shelf. Anybody is north of 40 in this audience.
Are you not surprised? I'm surprised. When I watch, you know, as you do, you watch a playback of stuff when you're shooting something and say, I know what I'm trying to do as an actor. I'm trying to have a certain, but this is so heavy now,
that I look concerned when I'm just supposed to be listening. And so to get, I think we talked about this on the podcast, when I want, I have to tell myself, when I want to just be level, I have to tell my face to be semi-surprised. Just a little bit, so now it's neutral. So semi-surprised is alright. And then if I wanted to seem happy, I have to think, ebulient. That's a long, yeah.
Because in the morning, I try to keep my distance from you because I'm like, is he pissed at me? Yeah, you're just like, that's my good morning. He's a little, he's a little bit grumpy. I'm a little bit grumpy. Yeah, I'm a grumpy. I'm a grumpy. little bit grumpy. Yeah, I'm a little grumpy. I'm a little grumpy. You're coughing and then you're good.
I am moody. All right. Man, we've covered a lot. We're not even supposed to be talking to you. We're supposed to be talking to ourselves. I know, I know, it's so crazy. It's a little nuts. It's a little surreal, but.
Is this just to just the lace? No, just a snap. The snap. The snap. I'm wearing my sport piece tonight. It snaps. But they come loose. I didn't realize it was going to be so windy. But the helmet you slept in shaped it nicely.
Yeah, it keeps it. Well, it holds it. Yeah. I'm not stupid, dude. These nice new clothes were wearing. I know. I'm not stupid, dude. In these nice new clothes we're wearing. I know. We wear this on the podcast. We look at jammers in the podcast.
Yeah. All right. Shall we? Oh, you want to get going? I'm sorry. Are you, uh, you ever heard out? What are you doing? No, I felt bad.
Did you guys enjoy the check-in? Showing your vaccination? It takes you long, right? Where's your hat? Where's my hat? with a check-in showing your backs in ASAP. It takes too long, right? Where's your hat, Sean? Where's my hat? I know. This is it. No, I thought I'd, I'd, I'd, not wear one.
You usually wear a, that's why I'm wearing a ballad question. They'll wear one. Otherwise, I tell, I look like a pet a file if I, I don't know. Can I watch your kids, you know? You know? So I just tried to, Can I watch your kids? You know? So I just tried it. It just takes a lot of...
You'll see. It takes too long to do something. So I got a lot of product in it. That's why I wear a hat. I'm like, I'm too exhausted and an old... Did, now, did Scotty, did Scotty tell you not to wear a hat on the tour? Yes, he did.
He did, right? I knew him. Yeah, he's like, you're not gonna go out there looking like an asshole, are you? Yeah. You thought it would take you about half a dude? Right. All right.
This is your guess, is it? Yeah, yeah. So, drink up. Oh, yeah. And by the way, just to remind people, we don't know who this is. We do. We do. We legitimately don't know who it is.
So we never do. And we never do, but we've carried this on. Actually, the exception is Kamala Harris and Stacey Abrams, we all knew about, because there was a lot of apparatus to organize that. Yeah. Yeah. But other than that, I think we've always not known. Not known.
And that is totally legit. But this took some doing because this person is backstage and they had to be in a certain area backstage. They had to be brought here from out of town and they had to. So it was a big deal to keep it from these guys. And we can. And some other people in the tour know who it is.
So we keep on having to say the special guest. Do you have questions on you? Do you have your intro memorized? I don't have my intro memorized. My intro's kind of winging it. If you could keep them out. I've got my cards. You can keep them out.
By the way, I don't want to hold them. I don't think you understand the concept of winging it. You can't look at fucking no. Those are my questions. Those are my questions, not my intro. OK. Here's something I've never admitted this to because you do your little intro sometimes, which are obviously written right before.
Yeah, right before. And I'm not sure. I know I spend time on mine. Here's an admission. I've never written one. That's clear. That's clear. Never what?
I've never written an intro. Oh. Really? No. Why? No. Why? Because we're going to get to them. Did you write one for this person? I did not.
No, this person doesn't need an intro. Oh. Oh, really? This person legitimately is someone who has worn many, many hats. Oh. This person has been... This person was a cop. Um...
As a cop? America's mayor? This person was a cop. Is that his coming out? I would like that interview. Wouldn't that be fun? Turn up the heat and hear a little bit. Get some sweat going.
LAUGHTER Great. We got our first cut. Turn up the heat and hear a little bit get some sweat Great We got our we got our first cut. We got our first thing we have to cut. Why is that bad? That'd be a good interview. Do you so this person was a cop that this person has been a cop this person has been a race car driver This person I'm telling you this person went a lot of different cats. This person has been a figure skater. This person is America's best friend. This person has been a basketball player. This person has been and will always be to me the funniest guy that I know.
Mr. Will Fowl! Oh I'm so mad at you. Okay. I asked you, is there a dress code? You said... You said... It's formal. Tuxedos and cool sunglasses. I took them. You specifically said... That was when it was gonna be in Toronto. And I swear, I don't see mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I mean, I'm happy to do it. You guys didn't have to pay me the fee that you're paying me.
They don't know. They don't know. They don't know. Is that the same outfit you wore on the plane? This is so high. OK, you guys flew me first class accommodations. I was not allowed to bring a change of clothes, though. That was the stipulation.
What do you mean? But yeah, remember when people used to dress up on a flight? Yeah. I would bring a change of clothes, no, that was the stipulation. We don't need it. But yeah, remember when people used to dress up on a flight? Yeah, my dad tells me, no one does it anymore. I'm trying to bring it back. My mom was a stewardess for flight attendant for Pan Am. Their outfits were incredible back in the day, right? With the bowler hats, right?
And everyone had to wear a suit and tie in first class, I think, right? Yeah, and to be fair, just to catch that mistake you made. Um, Philbox, to underline it and highlight it. Oh, stewardess. Yes, at the time, she referred to... What I was gonna say was in your defense at the time, she referred to herself as a stewardess.
Yeah. Well, that's what it was called back in the day before. But you used to call her a waitress. She used to call her a waitress. She used to call her a waitress. But why did they switch it? Guys, it's a- We know, I'm a tour.
I know. Let's not get to you for the last night. Or we have him colors. The pan-hem classic. Yeah. Blue and white, and a little bit of teal, right? Wasn't there a teal? And splash of gold.
This splash of gold. Right for the wings. Did you have the travel, the shoulder bag? The Pan Am shoulder bag, oh sure I did, at all the swag. And we used to be able to ride with mom for free if there's empty seats. And then I would help out mom serving dinners to people.
I'd walk or I'd walk on my life. No, you did it. I'd walk or I'd walk on my life. No, you did it. Are you being serious? No, you did it. On my life, yeah. I'd walk down with their tray and can see that. And every time I've had you work in, even on vacation.
Oh, I'm sorry. I was on the nap. I'm sorry. Oh, you're evil. I flew all around the world, perfect. You were thrilled to do it. It's thrilled to do it. Now, we had to be in suit and tie, including my sister.
No. But you had to be dressed suit and tie including my sister. No, but you had to be dressed up and you couldn't check a bag because we never knew if we could get on the plane or not because you could only get on the plane if there's empty seats. So you had to be carry on bags. Oh, sorry, man. So let's get back to Will. Okay. It's February. Sure. It's pretty much the start of the year, so I thought I'd read my New Year's resolution. We're going to double back to the Pan Am story, because he's got something he really did the audience a favor.
Stop! Stop saying pun unintended. That's a good note. Because I love puns. Whenever I use it, I mean it. Okay. Otherwise you just wouldn't say it. Why?
You're not going to do it if you don't intend to make a pun. You say it's like sayingintended after murdering somebody I'm just He's trying to wiggle in a promotion for murder bill coming on They applauded pretty quick they're aware of it. They haven't seen it yet. They haven't seen it yet It's very good. That's kind of you to say I mean keep talking really commit That's very good. That's kind of you to say. I mean, keep talking about that. Really commit.
I really want to commit this year to referring to all money slash cash as cheese or cheddar. Sure. And fully commit to it. And fully commit, and $100 bills as blue cheese. Do you? So I'd like, yes, I'd like to, can I have a couple of those in blue cheese? At the ATM, you can request. Yeah, we're love for you to say your agent calls us, as well we've got an offer, and your only thing is,
how much cheddar are they offering? Right. Next person that says to me age before beauty, I'm going to knock out. OK. You just don't like it? Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
Oh, why? OK. Can you just don't like it? Okay, say 2022 in the house as much as possible. Eat more vegetables. Sure. Well, that would make a lot of sense. That's a good one. Do you guys not look at him and just fall in love? I can't swear. I could just stare at it the funniest man in the world. Yeah. Absolutely. Please.
No. All right. Drink at least 50 liters of water a day. 50 liters. That seems like a lie. Do something special for a random stranger every day. That's nice. That's nice. I got you picked by their coffee for them. You know, help someone cross the street and then ask a stranger to do something special for me. That's right. Stuart, just pick one.
This comes back to getting the face of flight attendants because I have rights, too. That, I think, has a head full of steam already. Just follow that trend. Yeah, I got it. Never buy a pack of cigarettes again. There's plenty of half smoke butts out there with at least two or three drags left on them.
So you just gotta look on the ground. Don't shake your head at me. Wait, that might go double for cups of coffee. Right. I got a lot, by the way. I'm glad this list is so long. I mean, you should have said, well, you don't fall through, I don't know.
This list is like even five more minutes long. It would have been nice if you started with buckle up. Tell my wife, I love her at least once a month. And then treat myself to a nice piece of jewelry. Remind myself daily that I'm afraid of no-gos. It's good. You're through. Can you forward these to me? I will. Really try to stop breeding exotic big cats. Mostly tigers and jaguars. Really pride. Mostly.
Mostly. Put all my money, all of it. Every last penny. All the cheddar. In Bitcoin. Do not look back. Take down my Christmas tree. And we will be right back.
Smartless is sponsored by BetterHelp. Now, there are times when I'm feeling my feet firmly underneath me, and other times when I'm kind of wobbling around. You know, mentally speaking, if you know what I mean, Shiny, huh? And I like a little bit of help. And what's better than BetterHelp? D.C. Right. Okay, this is the thing. I mean, Shawnee, huh? And I like a little bit of help. And what's better than better help?
D.C. Right? OK, this is the high level stuff. By the way, do you feel like you're a beautiful girl? I feel pretty good. Like today, I wouldn't bother the people at better help today. But it's nice to know that they're there when I do need it.
I mean, sometimes in life we're faced with tough choices, Shawnee, and the path forward isn't always clear. Whether you're dealing with decisions around career, relationships, or anything else, therapy helps you stay connected to what you really want while you navigate life. So you can move forward with confidence and excitement, right, Sean? Trusting yourself to make decisions that align
with your values is like anything. The more you practice it, the easier it gets. But seriously, folks, therapy has something that has really helped me through a lot of things in life, especially in the last 10 years of my life. So if you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge.
Let therapy be your map with better help. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartness today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp.hlp.com slash smartness. Looking for love? I'm Jujube and on this season of Queen of Hearts, we're going all the way down to sunny sexy Miami. I'm setting up the hottest singles in South Florida. Maybe I can find them their perfect partner or someone to fulfill their sexiest fantasies. A man who unconditionally loves me and is a raging feminist and then ties me up rubbing oils on me then surprise gets a girl to lick my foot
and another guy to put it in my foot and has a huge... But remember there's a twist no one can see each other until the very end. Cameras on! Oh hi! Hi! Woo! Got me blessed! Follow Queen of Hearts on Amazon Music or wherever you get your podcasts.
You can listen ad-free on Amazon Music, included with Prime. Download the Amazon Music app now, or you can listen ad-free by subscribing to Wonder RePlus and Apple Podcasts or the Wonder App. Raising kids can be one of the greatest rewards of a parent's life. But come on, someday's parenting is unbearable. I love my kid, but is a new parenting podcast from Wondry that shares a refreshingly honest and insightful take on parenting. Hosted by myself, Megan Galey, Chris Garcia, and Kurt Brownleur, we will be your resident
not-so- so expert experts. Each week we'll share a parenting story that'll have you laughing, nodding, and thinking. Oh yeah, I have absolutely been there. We'll talk about what went right and wrong. What would we do differently? And the next time you step on yet another stray Lego in the middle of the night, you'll feel less alone. So if you like to laugh with us as we talk about the hardest job in the world, listen
to, I love my kid, but wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. And now back to the show. Avoid slipping into vocal fries so much. Right. Yeah. You guys know what that is. I just found out what that was about six months ago. You know, when you talk like that, I'm like, God.
It's like Valley Girl's Peak, right? That's going back a bit. Every sentence ends in a question mark. No, it's talking like, you know, like that's... Isn't that vocal fry? I got one more example. I don't want to do it again. I did.
All I see are two cameras over there, and I don't. I don't can't do it again. Thank God for the internet, huh? Because that will hide you for so long. By the way, Willing, again, this is starting to read like a manifesto, but go ahead. Chicago. Chicago PD.
Chicago Fire. Chicago Mad. These are the three shows you're promising to watch this year? No, I just love them. You love them. Yeah. It's actually an ad. It's actually an advertisement. That's a paid ad.
It's a paid ad. That I snuck on with Smart List. What the fuck? What the fuck? Thank you guys. Speaking of Chicago, you look dangerously close to Harry Carey right now. Oh, did I?
Yeah. Yeah. I'm trying to ag him on just a little. Chicago peed in! Oh! What I love is it has all the thrill and excitement of the inner workings of a police department. With all the backyard knowledge of Chicago. Wait, you know, I'm from Chicago and. What's more excited than solving a homicide at Rigley Field?
I'm sorry, I got a lot more. Should I stop it? No, listen, I mean. Our guest don't show a preparer. No, this is what a jack- I'm gonna speed through. I'll speed through. I don't really have questions.
Try the last questions. Try to work on my intense hatred of manatees. Yellowjackets streaming now on Showtime. Oh, Jesus, man. What is that? Suck an ass. Hollywood has got you in there. You don't know how much blue cheese I just landed right there.
Well, not yet. Not yet, but when this airs. OK. All right. Finally, finally changed my name to DeBaby, It's not yet, but when this airs. Okay. Alright. Finally, finally changed my name to DeBaby, unless it's already taken. Or finally changed my name to Yay, unless that's already taken. No, you're good. They're both taken.
How do you spell it? Why? No, that's taken. What is it, yay or ye? Well, I thought, like, why, a-y isn't taken if you want that. I just want, why, I just want y-e. You can't have it. Taken?
Taken. I don't know. I mean, if you're pronouncing it like the way you're doing it, I think that you're good. I mean, I should preface it by saying, I'm not a lawyer. Wait, does Kanye want it pronounced yay or ye? Ye? Ye? Ye? You see, you're hearing Vogue.
I just thought of a fourth one, Chicago Law. Oh, Chicago Law. You can play a lawyer. Shit. If, by the way, now, this is like a trademark thing. It's her name, Mike Davis. Sounds like Terry Seattle. He does, I like Terry Seattle.
Terry Seattle. Remember to have like Terry Seattle. Remember to talk louder on my cell phone when I'm in public, especially on an airplane. Eat more roadkill. More. If we all ate roadkill, at least one mill a week, we'd reduce our carbon footprint by 25%. You almost couldn't get that one out. You like that one. Land voice over contract for Reese's peanut butter. What the fuck? And don't be sorry about it. Don't so worried about it. Good luck.
Will, can you roll down your sock a little bit more? Sorry. Just get it all the way down. Come on. Jason and I got an argument for real just before the show because I did have a Reese's Peanut Butter Cup. Also paid ad ends. Jason said, in that way, he goes, oh, it's so funny. I said, how long you do, thank you Will.
They're really funny, by the way. I actually stop it's so funny. I said, how long do you do? Thank you, Will. They're really funny, by the way. Thank you, man. I actually stop and watch them every time I see them. Thank you. It's so nice to get a compliment from a friend. Whoa. Fuck it.
I mean, the last great commercial I saw was the Dodge thing that you did way back when. Remember that was for Dodge, wasn't it? Right, yeah. Have you done a commercial since then? I did one for GM. Oh, GMC. Not GMC, not GMC trucks.
No, not GMC. So you did GMC, he does GM cars. That's the GMC, right? GMC is a truck, is a division of GM. What's GM? That's the big overall company. Yeah. General merchandise.
I don't like me. I thought I would talk about light trucks. No, we talk. I mean we're talking about professional great vehicles And we've only been doing it for 23 years look here's the point Here's and we're not like a world record and vice-vers. I don't know It might be but I try not to someone Google it. I tried not to talk about it in front of people It might be, but I try not to... Someone Google it. I try not to talk about it in front of people.
In front of the theater of... Pax theater of people? No, because it's gross, but... Uh... But you love it. I love it. But you're a good match for it because you are kind of a professional grade kind of guy, right? It fits him.
Thank you. Well, the voice alone is like a truck. It sounds like a truck. It's burned out. Who sings that song, believer? Don't stop believing? No, believer. Imagine dragging these nuts across your face. Is that on my list? See that, Borg. The last one is whatever dragon. Let's say that more. The last one is whatever dragon you're not. Which is not really a resolution, it's just a reminder to take chances. Uh-huh.
And be more spontaneous. Yeah, yeah. Even though it's on my list. Well, it makes me think, it's not finished. It's not done. OK, it's my last one. I don't know.
Remove all and repeat all of my music from Spotify, all my albums. There we go. Oh, all my albums. All of them. All of them. You think cupcake party. Shhh.
All my back. Go revolution yesterday. Not on back. Go revolution yesterday. Not on there. Grandma's unicorn. Jesus clown. That's a B side. Even the B side. Get it on.
And will why? Here we go. Here we go. Why are you talking about me? Because. Because it's a bad platform. Yeah, it's a bad. Yeah, yeah.
Because you have a lot of glitches. Yeah, a lot of glitches. Yeah, it's a bad. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Because you have a lot of glitches. Yeah, a lot of glitches. And your music is pure. Is that it? We're getting there. We're halfway done. That was it.
That was it. Yeah. Will Ferrell's New Year Resolution. But Will, so sitting here thinking and being- That's our time. Oh, wait, hang on, he's getting a call. He's taking a car you face Will I gotta say sitting here on the stage I was gonna say and doing that and and I was thinking and
With all these people with all these people here Do you miss and I know we've asked you this before but how much do you miss Performing every week like you did for a long time. You guys are front of an audience. Are you joining right now, Sean? Am I right? You were kind of yawning, weren't you? I started, I've been yawning for 20 minutes. Let's see.
LAUGHTER Sean, Jason forced Sean to walk a lot earlier today. You guys were on the birds all over the city. Yeah, I heard. Yeah, yeah. We did the birds, but it started as a walk, and then this is very exhausted. I, I'm not. You make me laugh harder than anybody.
I didn't even sleep last night, right? I didn't sleep. I got up at like three or four in the morning because these guys are like, they can do the switch from, I wasn't supposed to use ghost time. Like, it was problem. I need like two weeks, and I don't have it. Right. But it should be, two weeks and I don't have it. Right.
But it should be, you are a little bit tired. I'm okay. Why is everybody on my back about being tired? Because you were yawning when Will was doing. I was not yawning. I was like, this is my thing. I was like, okay. Good God.
Do you know? Look at the foot. Maybe it's a different problem. Do you know what a yawning is? I'm pretty sure I can identify a yarn when I see it. You know, I did a small scene in a movie with Kevin Hart, and I was doing my... Yeah, thank you. Thank you.
And we're doing my single, right? So the camera's on me, and the person that you're talking to is behind the camera. Right here. So, okay, right. So then, so Kevin Hart's face is right here, and I'm talking to him. We're in the middle seat. The Hollywood bounce guard.
Falls asleep. He fell asleep while he's off camera. Camer's rolling. Who K-Hurt? Kevin Hart fell asleep while I'm doing my single. Wow. I'm talking literally his eyes close, and I thought, well, my only somebody has the guts.
And then... While you're performing to do it. K-Hurt, been a guest? No. That'd be a good one. Yeah. You guys could break that down. I'd like to talk to him about that.
Yeah. Let's call him. Is that phone still in there? No, wait, I want to go. I want to to talk to him about that. Yeah. Let's call him. Is that phone still? I want to go back to this thing. Do you have a problem like I do with the changing because you travel a lot too and you that's the thing I don't understand about you guys who do like movie after movie after movie after movie is like how do you adjust and then have the energy after 14 hours to just get up and go like be fun ambient coke. Yep. Okay. Those are the two that looks in the old dot kit.
Yeah. That's what he taught me. He told me you're going. I got two dot kits. One's brimming. You've been blowing about that. It spills out. Everytime. You're really open about your cocaine use, right? You have been for-wind about that. It spills out.
You're really open about your cocaine use, right? You have been for a long time. I've never hidden that from anyone, not a soul. Yeah. The kids, you know what backstage, it's true story also, that we were trying to figure out Jason was, what is a dop kit? What does that mean?
We looked it up. Do you know why it's called the dop kit? Does anybody here know? Why? Why they call it dop. You know what a dop kit is? Do you know what it's called? It's called the Dopp Kid. Does anybody here know? Why? Why they call it Dopp? You know what a Dopp Kid is? Do you know what I'm saying? It's gotta be.
Some people refer to it as a toiletry bag or a shaving kit. Dopp Kid. It was anybody? Germany, yeah. Yeah. And what about it? This is all a boy we're trying to root out the Germans.
He's right there! Get him! We're right there! Get him! Get him! Get him! Now it's Dopp Kid! We got there! It! Now it's... Dupcic! That's the same word! His son is pounding him right now.
Do you see? No, it was a guy who was a leather smith in Germany and he came up with a toilet bag and to begin the Dupcic. Was his last name Dopp? Doppelt. Does that sound right to you, sir? Yeah. Well, of course it does.
The German. I wanted to ask you this before. Who is your favorite, historically SNL performer? No, historically. Like, so you can go like before you, like when you were a kid that you watched and you were like, I love what that person does. Other than Gilda. Other than Gilda and Jim Balushi. Or John. Or John. No. Eddie Murphy pretty, pretty, pretty fun to be. I feel like it all kind of happened in various increments.
Right. For me, it was Dan Accurate, the first time I started. Yeah. Because I just thought, oh, that guy, who's this other guy? What? Dan Accurate. No, I thought you said somebody else. What do you see?
I thought you said a second person. No, I'm your friend, not your dad. You have, this is about to. I was about to. But you have a beef with Sean, a little bit. You have been fighting for years. Tell them, tell them about your fight. Don't maybe pull up the emails.
I mean, they're scathing. I am. I emailed Will today and I said, Sean hosted once. Yeah. And we just got off on the wrong. LAUGHTER He just came in all sassy and... I think we talked about this on the podcast maybe before.
So forgive me, but one of the hardest times I ever laughed in my entire life was when we hosted and you came out and you didn't tell us in a schedule for me and you and Jimmy Fallon that you came out with a little tiny phone. Yeah. Yeah, Jeffree's. Jeffree. Jeffree's. God, that was so funny. Yeah. Jeffries. Jeffries.
Jeffries. Jeffries. God, that was so funny. Yeah. And what was the other thing you did? Oh, and you came out on a scooter, which you didn't do in rehearsal. So you did not have the numbers?
No, it was like, actually. It was a little jazzy. Yeah, the electric, oh my God, it was so funny. But so. There was no reason. Well, so funny. Dan Ackroyd. Yes. Eddie Murphy. Yeah, and Phil Harman.
Yeah, Phil Harman. The great, so great Phil Harman. Don't worry, let's not forget about Bill Murray. But you know what he is, probably you say Phil. You just sparrage any of the customers. But those guys. Let's do that too. Yeah.
Okay, so these are the ones I hate. Yeah, she's in my bottom three. Okay, bottom three. Yeah. You guys, you go first. I don't know why you're so on top. I don't know why you're the mom. Wait, do you like, you know what's so funny about, because, you know,
it's kind of like when you have a teacher in school and you see them out of the grocery store, and you're like, oh my god, it's so bizarre. It's like, I didn't see you as a real person. I didn't see you as doing anything else than teaching in that room. And so for me, I always see, you've done so many movies and I've been so successful and everything you do, every appearance you do, you're always so unbelievably funny.
I always picture like, what does he do on a day? What are you doing now other than doing this? Like, what do you do when you're not moving? It's terribly boring. Yeah. It's very, what does a boring day look like in your life? OK. Take one of my children to school.
Just the one. The other one is learning at home. They don't deserve to learn. They don't deserve me. We draw straws at the beginning of the school year. Yeah, what's called the private school tuition bucket. And we only got enough money for one kid. By the way, he has stallions, by the way.
Our kids go to school somewhere near one another and everyone's in love with his kids. Like, these are these are models. One of my boys maybe sort of knows your daughter. Hey man. Through friends. So you see where I'm going with this? Yeah.
My daughter's bedroom walls are filled with the young feral. No, I'm kidding. But yeah, no, they nice nice gene pool there. Thank you. So boring day because I have a feeling. Not so much my work. I have a feeling it is similar to my boring day, probably close to your boring day too,
and yours as well. Try to exercise a little. A little drop off, little exercise, work in some lunch. What's your lunch look like? No, but I mean like it. What's your way? And you know about his unhealthy relationship with food. Go ahead.
No, but I bet he, I think you are a healthy eater. I don't know what I'm basing that on. I mean, sort of. Yeah. I think you're basing it on the nice fit of the suit. Well, I used to see, but I also used to see Will out jogging. We used to be a similar jogging loop.
So you like, you enjoy a healthy body. So you putting good fuel in that body? A lot of laughter during a healthy body there. By the way, can I thank him for all of us that he's so willing and generous to show his body in almost everything he does? Yes. I mean, the crumb cake hairdo on the chest is just... That's a lot.
That's two and a half hours of makeup. Oh, I am. So good. I'm like a candle. You look at me. I am just... Shades down the channels, whimmer. Yeah, channel, exactly.
That's just a chest and belly plate you put on. I remember sitting at a screening preview of some movie where I was shirtless, literally behind an audience member who went, oh boy. Oh, here we go again. Here we go again. It's so good. That and the other, remember, going to Sneaking
into a movie to see it on opening weekend when they're used to opening weekends. And listening to one kid go, he's got a lazy eye. Look at him, he's got a lazy eye. I'm sitting right behind you. I sat right behind... He's got a lazy eye. Do I have a lazy eyes? I sat right behind Ron Howard in this wonderful film that he directed at a screening for like 12 people, it was the first time a screening.
And right when it was done, he turned around and I go and he goes, oh, hey Sean, I go, hey, is the picture locked? I have a lot of thoughts. Did he go, or he was like, you're not wiping me in? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, I mean, it was his face. I was sitting next to somebody in a movie theater, packed a movie theater for a very, very good movie.
You all sold out, it was one empty seat in the house. And I'm sitting in a back row sitting next to somebody. And they don't, we don't, we haven't looked at each other. They don't know why I am. And a trailer comes on for a comedy that I, a trailer was not that great, not one laugh through the whole trailer, trailer ends. And then there's the silence as it goes black, and then another trailer's about it.
But during that science, this guy thought he'd be funny and he said, no thanks. And then, it echoed. And I was, I was sitting there, I'm thinking, well, that was pretty good, but wouldn't it be better if I just tapped him right now? Yeah. Because like, I think my face was like the last face
on the trail, like, he's gonna know, he's gonna recognize. And I did. You did. Who did it? I tapped him on the shoulder. No, first I squared up to him, so I knew as soon as he turned to be looking at that, that tattoo he looked at,
I go, not for you. But then we were buddies, and we were laughing the whole way through the next one. Nobody delivers that shitiness better than you. I swear to guys, the fuck, you're best. It's so funny. But he killed it, and he got a huge laugh with the note, thanks. But if you ever had he got a huge laugh with the note, thanks.
But if you ever had those, you ever have those people. Have you had at a premiere of something? Yeah. People come up, this happened to me. Parents of someone who worked on the film, dad grabs them by their shoulders, like, I don't care what they say, I loved it. Yeah.
I was gonna say. Oh, what did they say? They were saying, they were already saying it? Yeah. I was gonna say, oh, what did they say? What did they say? They were already saying it? Yeah, it's not even in the theories. I've had friends, like specifically, like friends that you grow up with, and then you go back to your home telling, go back to your owner.
I had a few friends go like, got that last one, huh? Not very good. As if like, hey, we're inside, and I can say to you that what you do for a living sucked And you're like yeah, I guess I mean I we haven't agreed on it, but I guess now we have so I I had this friend come back after a show I did the promises promises I'm Broadway and Everyone up. Rob is his drum. Rob is his drum. Rob is his drum. Rob is his drum. Take a bow, Sean. Take a bow.
Take a bow. Okay. So, do one. Do one. Do one. Do one. Do one. Do one song from it.
I have a little bit. No, and this person came up. I didn't know this person very well, and they said, one sees such a performance, and one can only say, Sean Hayes. You're so... Yeah, that's sort of a bittersweet. Yeah, I love those. It hurts.
No, it's not so bad, that's fine. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Now, Will, what's being a back thing? What? What do you say we all do a cold reading of a scene from the OC? LAUGHTER Sean, you'll play Luke.
I thought you were going to be... Sean, you're playing Luke. Uh, Jason, you will be Seth. Okay. You're going to be Seth. You're gonna be Seth. We're all playing. And they're all highlighted. Each of our lines are highlighted.
You're gonna play the part. You're playing Marissa. None of this is prepared. I'm Marissa. I'm Marissa. For you. I'm Ryan. Ryan.
Yes. For you. I have to say, by the way, yes, what Jason just said, you were fucking crazy. Like, this is, I just thought of this today. Am I? But can we just say, can we just say thank you? Yeah.
Nobody, nobody ever comes on prepared. This is incredible. He's got, he's got, he's got index cards. He hasn't even gotten to it yet. I'm trying to make you guys laugh. Hey, I'm playing Marissa. Okay. So you don't have to thank him, but we're good.
Everyone, this obviously is a cold dream. So everyone's familiar with the show OC, the great OC. Great OC. Okay. What was the song, the OC, anybody? Oh, thank you. California, here we come. And in the band.
California. California here we come and in the band California I'm saying for real will sing for real. I would but I can't remember that one All right, let's let's get today You got a you got a fucking dinner day It is unbelievable how would we rush here? Okay? We it would be. Okay, we are interior diner, day. Yeah. In a casual little restaurant by the water, Seth, Ryan, and Marissa eat a meal.
Okay? That's your setup. Here comes a dialogue. See, guys, I've been thinking about a plan. You know, right now, this could very well be the first stop on our pancake tour of America. Hey, like on the road. Like a woman, your marissa. Marissa. I got this you guys. That's offensive.
Yeah. Right. Is it offensive because you think you sound plenty like a girl? First of all, first of all, I'm not auditioning for you. Hey, like on the road. There you go. That's my favorite book. Mine too. So here's the deal. Yep.
My mom had this boyfriend. He hired me to work construction last summer. But then they broke up. He moved away to Austin. In Texas? He said if I was ever out there to look him up. Well, I mean, well, that's really kind of far. We were thinking like, come at Long Beach or something so we could all hang out.
I'll need to get a couple of days work so I can get a little bit of travel money. Well, I mean, we can get you money. Ryan looks away, uncomfortable. Marissa and Seth seem to get the point. Well, I mean, you know, I guess in a way you're kind of lucky. One looks away, uncomfortable. Marissa and Seth seem to get the point. Well, I mean, you know, I guess in a way you're kind of lucky. You get to move to a whole new place.
Start over. Be whoever you want to be. That's really not so bad. Luke, Luke and a couple other guys walk in, banging on the door, banging the door on purpose and being rude and noisy in general. Hey, Puts. What's it take to get a menu around you?
That's great. That's great. Yeah. That's great. Okay, I'll handle it. And it does say Marissa stands up. Oh, thank you. That's all right. That's all right. I'll handle it. And ruin your popularity, you know what?
Why don't you guys just sneak out back? Marissa gets up and heads for Luke's table. LAUGHTER And ruin your popularity. What's going on with you, too? Hey! Oh, sorry, Marissa. Kisses Luke on the cheek and then takes a seat with him. CHEERING And then takes a seat with him.
And then takes a seat with him. And then takes a seat with him. Oh, and then takes a seat with him. Here we go. Thank you. I mean, you want the job or not? Okay, ready. Luke says...
How is the manicure? Oh, it was great. Well, Marissa distracts Ryan and Seth quickly leave their booth and head for a hallway toward a back exit. Marissa notices Seth and Ryan walking through and keeps talking, distracting Luke and the guys. So, what did you guys do today? Seth and Ryan try to hurry up, but Luke notices them. Hi, guys. How are you guys doing?
You like the food here too? Pretty awesome. Here comes, say it, Sean. Shut up. Okay. Seth says, well at least I don't shave my chest. Nice. Luke gets up. Oh God. What'd you say?
Luke, come on. I was just saying you look nice in a sweater vest. It was a compliment. Luke gets up and sets face. Alright, bring it. We got it on its feet real quick, by the way. We're just workshopping this. You want me to break you, Cohen?
Hey! How did I miss this episode? This show seems great. Just six pages left, guys. We're almost there. You guys have been so patient. Thank you. Hey, so then Luke says, no way, look who's back. Here he comes.
Oh, wait. Cute Luke. Oh, I got it. God damn it. No way. Cute, Louie. Oh, I got it. God damn it. No way. Look who's back. You know, you're a little far from eight mile. Louie, don't.
What did you, like, spokesperson for Geeks of America or something? Nice. That's a sick bird. They all laugh. They all laugh. Oh, Ryan laughs. Here comes big finish. You know what I like about rich kids?
Ryan Punches Luke in the face, hearted under the throwback, onto the table. Nothing. So that says that was awesome. Your asses, you're dead. That's it. See, thank you so much. I'm sorry. I mean, after a rough beginning, Wow.
After a rough beginning, Arnet killed it. Thank you. Thank you. Will Ferrell, I have a dumb fan question. Yeah. The fan is a really dumb question. Here we go from these two idiots.
Oh, that is. Where, what is your favorite movie that you work down with? What's a favorite? Well, what is something that you love to do that really sticks out to you? You can't tell his favorite. We love his movies, right? We love Will's movies. Good luck, bro.
But what was the one that you just like had the most incredible experience? You were proud of the result, all of that kind of stuff. Well, blades of glory. Blades of glory, starring Will. Will, do you guys know how you really pronounce his last name? The wedge? Arnett.
Arnett. Arnett. Actually, he's right. I had to know. In Canada, he's Arnett. Arnett. Arnett. It's true.
He moved down here and he started elongating it. What's the second reason? Is that true? Yeah. He knows that because my parents, my parents, my mom, my mom and dad are I was like no, it's will aren't it Whoa, whoa, whoa, really aren't it Guys this aren't it
Changes everything can I borrow your shades? Can I borrow your shades? It's gonna burn your shades gonna burn shade This changes everything yeah, so wait if your mom and dad introduced themselves to somebody, they would say, I am Mr. or Mrs. Arnet. Arnet. No, no, no. Now they say Arnet because they want to get the bump from being my parents. Yes. Oh, God.
That makes sense. Right. No, but they do. They want the juice. No, but they do say they do. My dad says, yeah, Jim Arnet. Well, yeah, we've talked about it. So he's been living a professional lie this whole time.
It's true. It's true. So my question, uh, favorite man, which one makes you laugh the most? And it doesn't have to be about you, it could be somebody else in it or the one, which one? I heard Alphire kicking and screaming. I heard old school. I heard. Zoolander was pretty ridiculous. The one that makes me laugh the most is. I can't do the best. That's what I think is something really obscure.
What's your, I would say, in terms of overall, if I had to pick one, it's Anchorman. Yeah. Oh, gosh. Just because, no. Oh, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, that's a, we love Anchorman.
What was your show called again? What was the what? What was your show? My TV show? My TV show? No, your Broadway show. I promise this promise is. There was a wondering standing ovation for promises.
That's true. That's true. Not so much for Anchorman. Not so much for Anchorman. But that was like we were for promise. That's true. Not so much for ink. Not so much for ink for me. But that was like we were playing with the house's money. There was like, why are they letting us make this? Well, when you went and pitched that movie to what's his name?
Husband and wife, team, where the producer is in. Yes. Walter Parks? Yeah, right, right, right. And will, apparently, this is legendary stuff. Will walked in, he was wearing a huge, they were trying to pitch, get the money to make Anchorman, and you and Kay went in. Well, we had to go in for a lot.
We knew it was not looking good. Yeah. People just did, we're not getting the idea. And so we're like, let's just go and mess around and pitch around. And you had a huge foam cowboy hat. Yes. And in the middle, we all did cross multiple parts
who's making the decision to make it. And there are people who are talking. And we'll stare them down. And then just interrupt it and said, I think I'm falling in love with you. I'm falling in love with you. I'm falling in love with you. We'll also came, we had an engagement party
years ago and we'll show it up, bringing a hat that said, I'm number one. To my, remember that? And you also, you had a hat, the Patriots had 19 or no? 19 or no. Yeah. Yeah.
That you wore two Boston, to Amy's parents house. To Amy's parents house. Yeah. After they had just lost the Super Bowl, that's right. To go 18 and one. Because they made one. You know, they make those hats in case they win,
they make the hats of the team can put them on. And if they don't win, they destroy them or they send them to some other part of the world where they can use the hats. And so I have to do it. People say that about our merchandise, but yeah. Yes, yeah. So it said Patriots perfect season 19 and O.
And a buddy mine got me one. And I wore it up to Boston Thanksgiving dinner. And I think Amy's dad was like, will, not funny, get that hat off. Oh, that is not fucking funny. Look at this guy, if I can choke, I have him canada. I'm hilarious, dude, Ashley, Bill Polar. I'm hilarious, dude. I love that you found a 19-to-no Patriots.
I know, that's crazy. I think I still have it somewhere too. Yeah. So the- I lost the I'm number one half. Did you know I don't know what happened? It was a great one. But the so on SNL where you can pick a character,
write a character, and it only has to last three, four, five pages. So if it doesn't work, you never have to do it again. If it does work, you can repeat that character next week or with a film, you have to go make this full commitment into oftentimes a brand new character. Is that more scary for you that like, well, I can't change it now. I got to do 120 pages of this character over the course of a few months. How do you like the stakes of those two things? You're blond out.
You're burning! You are burning to look at that. This is your next interview. We've gone over. emoji thumbs up. Can't beat that. You can't beat that. Is it nerve-rack?
Oh, he's gone. I, you know, ignorance is bliss. Uh, I don't, you don't think about it. Yeah. For better or for worse. Charge ahead. Same stakes of doing one that lasts for one sketch versus a whole movie.
You're either picking up the debris later or somehow. Let me ask you this. You land on your feet and you're like, oh, somehow it. Let me ask you this. You land on your feet and you're like, oh, that worked. Let me ask you this. Have you ever done a film where you come in on the first day and you're doing one of these incredible characters that you do and you pull it off, you take huge swings, you always pull it off, am I wrong?
I'm right. Have you ever had a director that doesn't have a great sense of humor that might go, huh, can I talk to you for a second? And then the very first day, they don't get it and they want you to make a big change. Has that ever happened? Luckily, that is not, yeah. I've feared pretty well in that department. But I have had those moments and we might have talked about it when we did the podcast. I don't remember
yesterday. A year ago. When did we do that? Almost two years ago. So many gummies between them. Oh I'm sure. I got six in me right now. That was the experience. Well the two dop kits. Yeah yeah. Dop kits. Uh oh. Get more dop kits. No, this self-freshing up cooking dop kits. Running low. But that was kind of the experience on Elf in the sense that I just finished doing Saturday Night Live where a lot of that stuff pushed the envelope that I just finished doing Saturday Night Live where a lot of that stuff pushed the envelope. Here I was doing this PG family Christmas movie.
Running around New York City in my yellow tites. Sitting in my little, not even a half-banger trailer in front of the little electric heater. You're right. And just looking in the mirror, going, so it was you that had the self doubt. It wasn't foul for all of it. This isn't it, huh?
I was just like, this could be it. Wait, you know what, that's a good point. And instead, it's a big second. It's a tight second to it's a wonderful life as the best Christmas movie ever. Yeah, right? But that's a great point. So it's a big swing you's a tight second to, it's a wonderful life, is the best Christmas movie ever. Yeah, right? But that's a great point. So it's a big swing you're doing this character of Elle,
and you have, that's the thing is, you have no fucking idea. If it's gonna work, we're people are gonna laugh. But did you feel pressure from being on, this being your first movie, and did you feel like all eyes are new? Let's see if this guy's got it. Well, a little bit, and like I said,
it was an old school was in the can, but it hadn't come out yet. And really? So it was just like. For my sister Tracy in the can, man. Yeah. Just for people who don't know it in the can, man. In the can, man, shot, but not yet released.
That's right. And I don't want to say that, because I don't want to make you mad, because I know about your hair trigger. Oh. Temper. But Tracy almost got more applause than they could be. I don't think I did it.
Don't think I did it. Don't lock it up. Don't, don't fucking, don't do it. I am going on such a bender tonight. I'm gonna run around those monuments with a spear gun, fueled on cocaine, screaming trace's name. When you used to be addicted to day-old seafood or natural horror, don't get me going. Day-old lobster.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I get it. But yeah, so old school was in the... Yeah, so yeah, that was just such a huge... And James Conn, Jamie Conn, who was fantastic, and we're so lucky to get him
another moment at a premiere, a comment, he was like, great job. I got to tell you. Because he didn't think so during, he said, I thought every day you were way over the top. You know? And you could see it on his face in the movie, but it works for the character.
And so I think he literally was like, what is this guy doing? You probably fired his agent six times during that shoot. But yeah, so that was like prime example of... It's all about process. Don't try to judge it too much. Just keep plowing ahead because you could look at it later and be like, oh, that was working the whole time. Well, your commitment is just, we're so lucky.
Yeah. Let's take commitment is just, we're so lucky. Yeah. Let's thank Will Ferrell, everybody. Yeah. Thank you, guys. Thanks, guys. You're the best. You're the best. You're the best.
You're the best. You're the best. Keep that. I want to give you something now. Keep that. Keep that. Keep that. Right this way, William. Do I leave? I I leave yeah, okay You're already on the phone. He's already on the phone. Look at the string on the back.
He's gonna cigarette butt. And he left this cigarette butt. He left this cigarette butt. You guys got Will Phill. Yeah. How... Nice job. I just thought for our first show,
I wanted to have somebody who's a friend of the show, and he was the first person that we actually interviewed. He wasn't our first broadcast, but the first guy that we interviewed. And I just wanted to have it to be like a friendly, you know what I mean? Make it be like a home game. Yeah, yeah, for sure.
I mean, I meant what I said, like I'm such a, like everybody is such a massive fan. He's never not funny on a talk show appearance, on a movie, on a TV show, on anything he's so prepared. By the way, and he came, oh, this is hilarious. He's holding us, oh my God, let's have that. Holding us. She's got a bunch of buys for us.
This is incredibly helpful right now. Yeah. Yeah. Because this is, we need to start thinking of how we're going to get out of here. And let's see here. Let's, well, I'll tell you what, so you guys take a look and I'll take a look and then I was going to talk with some more nice things about well. No, no, no, I know, but you can upload this and then back.
Put it right there so that the audience can't see. Huh, and they don't know. This is really cheating though. It's called the endless goodbye. I feel like if we use one of these too, we're going to get sued. Oh, good point. Good point. So anyway, so he shows up.
I was going to say, I was going to say he's never not funny everything he does and the commitment, the fact that he brought us these script, like he worked on scripts to do for us tonight, and then all of the other bits that he came out with, like that work, like you have to write that and think about that. So nice.
So always prepared and nice is kind of work. Super. Applause. He, super, super funny. You know, when we, when we did, blaze a glory, the first thing I, we, no, no, no, no, no, no. And it was like the first big movie that I did coming out of arrest of development.
And Will, thank you. And Will, oh wait, really quick, who went to the premiere of that? Albrechted? I know, Blades of Glory. I didn't. You did. Were be arrested? I know, I've played the glory. I didn't. You did? Were you there? How is that for you?
Oh, you were? Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Jason got mad for real again today about the fact
that Sean and I have vacation together a few times. But we love you. Really? Yeah, you're invited. You're invited. We're invited. You're invited. We're invited. But what does good thing is, like, of course, Will is hilarious.
And he's, like you said, super well prepared. Always does a funny bit. Always does something that you wouldn't think of. That's a special. Yeah, really special, interesting. But on top of it, he's the senior. He's the guy. He's already making these incredibly funny, great movies.
And I've known him for a few years, but getting on the set where that's his milieu, if you will, like that's where, and he was so gracious to everybody in the cast and me by being, you know, he was just always very generous. Well, that's the sign of a big superstar. Yeah. Like, you can't be an asshole. Yeah. I mean, you know, if you have to treat everybody equal, just work hard and be nice.
Well, I have that up in my office. Just work hard and be nice. And one day, one day you're going to do it. And we can't wait. We really can't. This is... I love you, too. Yeah.
I love you. Oh, you're the one who saw it. Thank you. We, uh... That was a funny script. Really funny. We love Sean, too. Oh, you were checking this out?
I'm not gonna look at those. Okay. That's a great question. We're not gonna take any those. Okay. We should write together. I want to write a message. That's a great question. We're not gonna take any more questions from the audience other than have you still, have you watched the rest of the development yet? Sure.
Yeah. What character does he play? Yeah. He played, remember I call it Job. No, no, no, I call it Gob. Gob. But I call it Gob. It is what?
It's Job, yeah. And? It's your, yeah. And? Wait, no, you are... Well, give me the first letter of your name. No, no, no. Just the first letter of his word. Damn. Oh, my God.
Can we talk about word-o? Oh, let's do it. And one of the other things is our big joke is like, oh great, yeah, send us your screen grabs a wordle. And also tell us what you think about the Beatles documentary. But I can't wait. And how is your work situation like succession? It's not.
But here, so we did wordle for the first time yesterday on the plane. And so, of course, we were making fun of it. We hadn't done it. So we did wordle for the first time yesterday on the plane and So of course we were making fun of it. We had it done it. Of course. It's great and then today today Jay goes All right, I can't wait for the next one. We're like no, it's only once a day. It's only once a day How does that everybody gets the same word? Yeah, right? So how are you not like? Seeing that on Twitter at the top of the day? I don't, how is this catching on? Because people have other stuff to do. Yeah.
Oh. By the way, all these buys are, thank you for the effort, they're all useless. They're not, they're not like, oh, I guess some of them do work. No, that one's good. That one's pretty good. You know what, what is good?
You know what, I went on my favorite. Here we go, now that's Sean right there. one's pretty good. You know what? You know what? Here we go. Now, that's Sean right there. He's about to do his body. He just... He's just the whole of that one. He's just the whole of that one. He's just the whole of that one.
I can break. God, you know what? It's going to be the worst. You know what? One of my favorite characters that will... What was it? What was it? Will Ferrell played.
It was Zintaladegan Naito. What was his name? Call? Ricky. Bye-bye! Bye-bye! Bye-bye! Thank you! Thank you!
Thank you, Washington DC. Thank you! Smart. Bloss. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Grandterry. Smart. Last. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.